as we approach the end of march and
women's history month we want to
highlight a school that's investing in
the next generation of women leaders
the alcoholman shows us the impact of
girls athletic leadership
school also known as gals here in las
vegas
movement is a regular part of girls
athletic leadership school
known as gals opening its doors for the
first time this year
this middle school is creating a
sisterhood i have more friends
and i can talk to more people
without people yelling at me i love miss
siobhan she's funny
and like i learn a lot in her class
about writing and reading
and english gals was founded by jennifer
mklowski closing the gender gap is her
passion and it stems from personal
experience
she worked in a male-dominated
professional environment for decades
i just have recognized that we need to
really help our girls
come out strong have clear goals have a
clear
understanding of who they are as they
approach and enter into the workforce
gals is a safe space for sixth seventh
and eighth grade girls there's a focus
on leadership
physical well-being college prep and
science technology engineering and math
opportunities
a school many women wish they had
growing up had i attended gals
back in the 70s when i was going to
middle school
i would have had a stronger voice i
would have understood myself better and
i would have been able to advocate for
my needs better
students who were failing at their other
schools notice a change the personalized
attention
allowing them to excel turning c's and
d's to a's and b's
the teachers are really helpful and you
could get a lot of work done
because in elementary school i did not
have good grades and now i do
i don't like math but i'm good at it so
this place made a difference
investing in the girls of today so that
the future is bright
for everyone they have an immense sense
of pride
they have an immense sense of i am
capable
i can i can be i can excel in the world
and and it's just been an amazing
transformation
that these kids have had and they really
do they walk around now with their heads
held higher
and they believe in themselves more and
they believe that they have more
opportunities bianca holman
8 news now the school is tuition free
and they aren't accepting applications
for the upcoming school year
we have a link for more information on
our website eightnewsnow.com